you need to be okay with being bad to
start because sucking is the first step
to being sort of good at something
I'm going to teach you everything I've
learned as co-founder of Reddit and an
investor in multiple billion dollar
companies so you can go from your own
idea to actually executing your dreams
there is no shortage of things that need
to be improved it's about realizing what
you're going to work on and then how to
actually get started most good ideas
have lots of competitors you should
listen to your customers you should
listen to their customers but pay no
attention to what they're doing
the best way to break in is building the
most basic version of your product and
even if it's janky it's proof of
execution if you're meeting with an
investor what you got to get across in
the first few minutes is that there's a
clear problem a clear need and a huge
Market opportunity if we get it right
let's get started
[Music]